with enough salmon for the final cook
i'm off to meet a guy who's been
innovative with iceland's geothermal
energy
i'm told he has a very unusual way of
baking bread
hey hi captain very good good to see you
man good to see you
oh boy you good yeah very good that is a
very
firm handshake yeah good grip good grip
what's going on here
i want to show you a real rye bread
right huh
a rye bread yeah i mean my gran makes
rye bread
so what's the secret about this one i
can promise you she never
made my bread like this we got here uh
four cups of rye
yep and two cups of flour right in the
same bowl
how old is this recipe is the recipe
from the family tradition yeah it is
late 1800s early 1900s yeah
good yes then you put on a glove
the glove yeah one glove a little butter
you got a proper bed oven
you take a little butter yes and you you
know
got you all of this inside all of it so
and that's it we don't leave it to prove
for 10 minutes or anything no
no so where are we going to bake this
thing
the ground is boiling underneath us
ready
it's a very active hot spring area
right here in this village we have a
huge hospital that we use to heat up the
well it's
all from these hot springs here the
geothermal literally takes care of
all the heating absolutely yeah wow
gotcha is that enough that's enough
all right so where where's the oven
right over there we have to do a little
work and by work
he means digging my own oven and burning
volcanic earth
with a shovel and by we he means me
you use the shovel before i have
definitely used a shovel
how far down we going bloody father can
you feel that heat there
and more it's okay we have the sun for
24 hours so we have plenty of time this
is true
the heat in here is insane yeah how big
a hole you want
until we see a quick bubble now yeah you
hit the spot right here right
you sound like my wife keep
shoveling okay right right to the right
okay ziggy don't get vicious on me
that's perfect put the pot now on top of
the bubbles
exactly yes
okay yes it's hot it looks pretty good
i'm bubbling away like mad yeah but the
temperature of that is hot i mean it's
really hot yeah it's about boiling
temperature that water when you get down
trust me
it's piping hot what a magical way of
cooking
no gas no electric just a beautiful
spring
you're almost done now we put the rock
on top of it we want to mark it you know
beautiful seriously now
how long is that going to take to cook
24 hours
ziggy i have not got 24 hours trust me i
ordered a big one
so why don't we just go straight to that
one you maybe dig that hole
well i mean you don't want to miss all
the fun
this is it this is it okay
moment of truth and this went in 24
hours ago yeah
can you hear it i can hear it ah that's
incredible yeah listen to that bubbling
yeah yeah that is insane
put it over here
ziggy it's a beauty honestly it's not
just a pretty face
that looks beautiful ah that smells
delicious
yeah it does look at the color of it all
from in there
ready yeah
[Music]
oh my god stop it
stop perfect but right i mean smells
amazing
i just may i just take a little slice
absolutely oh my lord ziggy i'm in
heaven yeah
look at that oh my god
i just want to dive in there this is
beautiful
a van
something quite special about slicing
warm bread
and then on top of the bread with the
bread amazing exactly
i mean this is a the most glamorous
buffet
in iceland tonight cheers look at that
um cheers
food fit for a viking yeah come on
come on
um wow goes well together you know
that is delicious honestly a marriage
made in a volcano
it's rich very dense it's sweet and
salty as well at the same time
yeah it's got me thinking because this
technique yeah
rye bread amazing thank you chef to chef
thank you
very nice take care you too that was an
extraordinary rye bread and see you was
right
unlike one i've ever tasted
[Music]
want to see more from my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips